[Music]
angela merkel is the most astonishing
and successful political survivor in
germany since reunification
[Music]
I'm gonna marry always want the people
around her those who work with her to be
very very loyal and not to talk to the
media by their own whoever breaks this
unwritten law will be thrown out
immediately
[Music]
she had to take the decision to throw
him out
because she is more but she wanted to
show her authority towards him when
Angela Merkel started in 1990 at the
cabinet of Helmut Kohl that she was a
very very good observer she listened
carefully and she learned a lot even in
or just in observing how her McCall is
doing politics
[Music]
when she dared to write the important
letter an open letter published in a big
German newspaper where she said goodbye
to the old horse like she wrote him oh
cool yeah that was a big strategy and it
came out to be to be true and to help
her to achieve the presidency of the
party
[Music]
she knew or she had the feeling that the
demands of society do not really
correspond anymore to the program of the
city and so she modernized her party in
an extraordinary way
[Music]
[Music]
she adopted the program of a party to
the needs of society and little less to
the needs of her party she keeps calm
and carries on which means she's not
intimidated by anything
[Music]
I mean America everybody knows it is
afraid of dogs
and she well she was like freezing but
she didn't show her fear and this is
typical for her she faces any situation
without showing her emotions or very
very few emotions
German people do have a lot of
confidence in Angela Merkel and one
point why they do have these confidence
is because Angela Merkel is leading a
very very modest private life so she is
regarded as being incorruptible
[Music]
you